we live in the church drinking is not
accepted it's not frowned upon no
particular you got a priest in the
puppet and he said today I am gonna talk
about the different Greek born of
Satan's satanical mind I have talked to
you about drinkin and talk to you about
drinkin and you've never listened to me
today I will show you a practical
experiment I have here a glass of water
at last whiskey and an ordinary old
common worm now you watch you watch when
I put that one in the water
peekaboo
he's still a knight now watch if I put
him in the whiskey pick him out he's
dead what is the message behind that my
father stands up he says if you drink
whiskey you'll never get worms but it's
easy not to drink here in America cuz
I'm sorry but you guys don't drink to
the same level as the Australians or the
British I've been living in England
night it's a completely different thing
you're the only people in the world we
play drinking games no one else plays
drinking games every time you got
drinking with an American guy that'd be
something local gay dude ever plead for
your pong and you're like what's beer
pong you got to get a ping pong ball you
got to get it in the cup if you don't
get in the cup then you have to chug
your beer you're like let me get this
straight night
I'm trying to get drunk yet you're
putting an activity in my way that may
impede me from getting to my beverage
they have this drinking game in the UK
do you wanna know what it's called
drinking this is how you're doing right
you go to the bar you get yourself a
drink only buy one for you you're only
competing against yourself you drink it
really quick as soon as you finish you
get yourself another drink drink drink
drink drink drink drink drink drink
drink drink drink drink
and if you get so drunk your friend has
to drive you home then you win we're
gonna drink and you're thinking about
driving don't do it and all it's not a
good idea cuz like I say you know when
you're drunk
you know when you're drunk you're doing
laps in the parking lot you can't find
the exit hello
some of you make it out to the streets
you know when you're drunk you're like
you know behind you you hear you know if
you hear if you hear the magical sound
one of two things will pop in your head
either one I'm okay I'm fine I can beat
this or two I gotta let you go babe I
want to go to jail
Tomica my lover
I'm gonna tell you right now again if
you can make the police laugh you have a
chance if you do get pulled over for
drunk driving okay pull over as slowly
and as safely as you can get order now
if you know for a fact that you are
gonna go to jail okay you're early
I'm gone have a little fun I don't mean
take off in a high-speed pursuit no no
no no don't do that cuz you're not gonna
get very far I mean if you're drunk and
you're not gonna go to jail hell and you
have tinted windows have a little extra
fun take off your seatbelt jump over to
the passenger side
throw your seatbelt back on and just
wait for the cop
[Music]
you have no idea how bad you're gonna
throw his ass off you guys he's gonna
come over to the driver's side with a
flashlight
you're sitting Meriden
he was here a second ago I don't know he
went
stiffly what mid-drive a hell not [ __ ]
up yeah not bad pretty good you know
what's wrong with this Singapore going
slang
Singapore sling what's wrong with
there's not a buck in it
there's no [ __ ] huh yeah what did I
tell you
yeah put some bike in it what you do you
know Hey
[Music]
[ __ ] you're in it now buddy
yeah perfect
you never do pass out nope but girls get
way drunker than dudes man
girls get way drunk group girls get so
drunk too all of a sudden it looks like
they they're downloading information you
ever see that [ __ ] right they just don't
be having a good time and then BAM it'll
happen they'll just be like oh man I was
my name ooh na na what's my name ooh na
na what's my name what's my name what's
my name ooh na na what's my name ooh na
na what's my name ooh na na what's my
name what's my name
[Applause]
I'm like what the [ __ ] did you just do I
just downloaded the new Rihanna song off
iTunes [ __ ] cuz girls can't keep their
mood together to whenever they're drunk
that [ __ ] changes every few seconds
right you never know what kind of mood
she's gonna be in from moment to moment
the girl just be like oh my god I love
this [ __ ] oh my god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Oh cake we made
I gotta I gotta ask you a really dumb
question the black guys drink like white
guys that comedy shows you get the white
guys at the comedy shows that they're
not nobody drinks like white people do
white people there is a difference right
yeah but black guys don't sip white
people guzzle and there is a difference
right yeah I mean the white what black
people so the comedy club she's a lot of
you know white guys coming in there you
know they're gonna make some cash black
people drink when they go out like I do
economy sips drinks a lot drinks a lot
of Heineken and drinks a lot of
Tennessee and coke you know women drink
a lot of girly drinks so the women
ultimately drink a little more than the
guys but guys drink Alani in a drink
top-shelf what black people go out they
try to you know treat themselves really
nice
well white people drink shots and they
get drunk you know I'm saying black
people do get drunk but we become drunk
white people are like immediately to go
somewhere they gotta be drunk culture
with drinking is just we got to deal
with the crime present black people act
that way sober doing things like we
don't have fun minutes yeah that's one
thing I tell black people white people a
lot of fun white people do a lot
sexually a lot of fun black people love
[ __ ] but it's not it's [ __ ] yeah
yeah it's like you know I got I got
buddies you know white buddies like what
but it's like funny and they'll send you
a pitch and go look at the culprit in
the corner so yeah the girls smiling but
he really showing me the baseball bat
and the [ __ ] that he shoved up and it's
fun but you know black women they love
[ __ ] but it ain't is not a lot of
baseball bags it's gotta be low respect
a lot of pee in this respect
you know it's like it's like that you're
inspecting her high knees
I saw a point on the finish was like she
trying to throw me around oh really
can you don't be trying spank of black
girls hiney
you can if you if you're just being
forceful if you like bounce you don't do
that like that I'm I used to do a lot of
um you know when I was really getting
deep in my did you once you figure out
certain things you learn how to you know
you get to the little spit thing you
know what I mean but I have this like
girls that some about girls doing things
and you supposed to be doing really sexy
so you know I just spit on my face you
know and I said do it do it so then I
would I just spit on their face but my
[ __ ] on the cheek and then I'll just
lick it off
and once that happen you can feel her
filth coming coming along once girls get
opened up to that filthy thing is just
it's it's it that is such a beautiful
[ __ ] matter Jimmy you don't like that
not to licking it off part that's just
just grossed out Jimmy for the first
total guy they picked for a guy spit in
his face he said the girls pretty good
face didn't bother me but a guy spitting
someone's face Hey all right so wouldn't
like that Black's don't drink because
they end up shooting each other no we
should have a sober dude that's at the
blonde disparity that's with a black
party shooting is a weed thing oh [ __ ]
Kristen I knew we get to this point go
ahead Chris Jesus crap the blackstone
the bikes upon the drinks does they
don't want to buy extra drink man you
sound rich like stop like it's a
cultural thing it's not a money thing
it's just we don't guzzle drinks cuz we
don't drink to get drunk it's social
it's just a social thing you white
people drink to get someone who'll drink
to get drunk you know see black people
playing the game where's there's a
[ __ ] funnel and a holes in a
his mouth doesn't happen before I ask
you the question it seems but you don't
see a bunch of [ __ ] sitting around a
tape or Courvoisier and pour Hennessy
they get they get tipsy and then you go
oh yeah but they don't have to drink as
much because you guys today dyeing black
girls maybe one a to dry a little bit
black guys drink hard harder [ __ ] right
yes we don't have fun with drinking I
going out and drinking 18 beers oh
trying to guzzle a tequila you liquor
it's a different Pacific sip it and
enjoy a little bit tags and the whole
thing would not you never did a keg
party
[Music]
[Music]
but when a willing victim Lewis
committed adultery his pills and the
straightest staff
[Music]